- Alright everybody.
Let's close out with something fun.
I found scrolling social,
this is what I'm liking.
Two years ago, a
Pennsylvania woman was living
in a converted ambulance,
traveling the country,
when she saw a TikTok of
a guy looking to propose
and marry a woman, sight unseen.
Immediately, she was all in.
Some may say this was
a questionable choice,
but it turns out those people
would be wrong 'cuz it worked
out better than either of
them could have imagined.
Just look.
- [Danielle] The wedding
weekend was surreal.
The following two years
we almost never left each other's sides.
We traveled all over the
country in the ambulance,
built out a second tiny home,
and we went on so many
adventures together.
Neither of us thought we would
last this long by any means,
but I am beyond happy that we have.
Happy two year anniversary. To us.
(audience cheering)
- Wow! We have these free
spirited lovebirds on the line
right now watching on WTAE
Pittsburgh's Action News 4.
What's up y'all?
(crowd applause)
- Hey!
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
First of all, Danielle, Gunnar,
y'all are adorable.
I'm leading with that.
I have to ask you though,
did you think this would actually last?
- No, not at all.
Not at all.
We expect to be here two years later.
- [Kelly] I know!
I, just, a crazy thing.
So what's the secret?
Why has it worked out?
- Yeah, so I think what
has really worked for us,
the secret sauce, is that we came
into it with absolutely no expectations,
and we really let our friendship blossom,
and then that evolved
into what we currently
have now, which is love.
- [Danielle] I also think
that our communication skills
have a lot to do with that.
I think that this is probably,
hopefully, the healthiest
relationship we've both ever had.
And yeah, so no expectations,
and amazing communication
I'd say would be the secret sauce, yeah.
- Also your incredible
rock and roll haircut.
I just need to talk about it.
Danielle, you have my favorite hair
I've ever seen on this show.
Congratulations. Thank y'all so much.
It's just such a sweet story,
and so interesting and different.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- [Danielle] Yay!
- [Kelly] That's not all though.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion
to Go-To Erasable Pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate people who throw caution
to the wind, just like y'all.
So, they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
- Oh my God!
- [Gunnar] Thank you so much!
- Awesome, thank you guys!
And thank you to all our guests,
are Dame Helen Mirren,
Adam Brody and Aly and AJ.
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not, well, try and change it.